i've loved following your journey for
nearly a decade on
total divas and now on total bellas how
long do the two of you plan to keep
inviting the cameras into your lives
it's a good question we've been talking
about that a lot
a lot lately we love filming reality and
we don't mind them but you start
seeing your kids and that's what you
have to start to think about like my
daughter hates me
right now she does yeah bertie doesn't
even let me take pictures but when
cameras come around it's
it's hard on her so i'm very respectful
of her space
both nicole and i always say like we
have to respect our families
and at any time where our families feel
like it's time for them to be done then
we have to think about that too
i was even telling brie even when i post
a photo of matteo on my instagram
i always get like i get a guilty feeling
and i was going to arm i'm like was that
okay should i not have done that
and i think because he doesn't get that
say right and so
i told her that i can maybe do a few
more seasons of reality tv but i just
can't raise my son in front of the
cameras i just don't want
him one day to look at me and be like
you never gave me that choice i want him
to have a normal upbringing
and when he's 18 he can choose whatever
it is he wants to do
because bree and i have felt this way
about her kids were like we'll see
why don't we transition a little bit
yeah it doesn't have to be just a
docu-soap we could actually do something
else that we're really good at
that we know drinking wine yeah i like
that how do you think you'll know
when it's time to say goodbye to the
cameras for me it's definitely gonna be
when
brian like just really is like free like
look at our kids look at the situation
is this what you want like to you know
and i feel like that's gonna be the day
i'm gonna be like
no i'm very protective of my son and so
that's why i think for me it'll be
definitely sooner than later because
even when we were filming stuff in the
hospital with our cameras like even when
they were doing his first
bath i was like i don't know like we
don't need to get this like though i
could tell like those moments for me
i don't i want to live them through my
eyes and not through a screen
i just i could feel that it'll
definitely be sooner than later oh
god what does sooner than later mean
does that mean this year
next year i probably i mean maybe a few
more years or less
when you think back on all the
incredible footage
of your lives over the last you know
about seven eight years
is there a moment that you're so proud
of and then on the flip side
what is the moment that you're like uh i
wish the cameras hadn't have been there
i hate that that's on television i
cringe
a really proud moment would be both my
births being on camera
it showed people like different style
births and just how hard it is and to
see
brian's face you know if he was a boy or
a girl to see his face when buddy came
out and he announced it was a boy
because i'm so out of it i didn't get to
see brian say
that but to relive that moment for me
was i was really just like
i don't know that was really special
priceless was priceless
and so um that was for sure like a proud
moment
i'm thinking the moments that were hard
for me is like when the cameras caught
during one of my comebacks the cameras
were there and a couple mistakes
happened in the ring like i've had
a hundred thousand matches like of
course some are i've been have mistakes
like to not be able to just be in my own
like by myself and kind of cry and be
upset
i have all these cameras and people
around me and it was hard to go through
that
i definitely have to agree with bree the
best is the birth because
even every time i watch i still get the
same feeling i get so emotional
so my least favorite would definitely be
when i got really wasted off tequila
that might be my favorite
and i got a massive fight with artem oh
my gosh
i was like salsa dancing the guy in
front of him i
i die every time i see that that is the
worst so
humiliating we have the cutest visitor
today
baby tayo hi how are you guys say hi
hi did you say hi show how you made
gosh the bellas empire is expanding yet
again
you've got this incredible collaboration
with kalugo
how did this come about nikki just the
fact that she finally joined the mommy
club
which we all were waiting for you know
um she always wanted to be a mom and it
was so great to finally see her become
one but her and i just started to
realize that here we're in it together
now we're both moms
every day you have your baby gear and i
told her i'm like you just see your life
is going to change you got to throw out
the louboutins
it's going to be a whole different ball
game we still love being fashionable but
being a new mom you just become so
selfless and
everything becomes about them and our
strollers
are absolutely amazing and they're
amazing for not only the baby but the
mom and dad and then we also created
just these amazing totes that
for me as a mom not only do they have
every compartment that is amazing for
mateo but that's them here
data to the rescue that's amazing for
matteo but my dad for us
mom yeah oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
how proud are you of the bellas in this
amazing collaboration
so so proud it's amazing the product is
great and taylor loves it we love to use
it you know of course
the root of this collaboration is
because you're both moms nikki let's
start with you what has this motherhood
journey meant to you oh it has been the
most
incredible journey so far of my entire
life like these past 10 months like
have i've been my happiest i've learned
so much
i've had probably more breakdowns
because mom guilt is real and you want
to be so perfect
and but the love like when matteo says
like mom or
mama and and the love he gives me i'm
like this is living this is
life i love that you guys always keep it
real i mean you just mentioned you've
had more breakdowns than you've ever had
in the past
what what are these little moments over
you know it could be like sometimes
like i feel like i feel as a mom whether
like if mateo
cuts his finger or gosh i'm trying to
think like well even like
we she will go we had to do some work in
la
and she couldn't bring mateo and like
the whole time
she feels like a bad mom and i'm like
well you need this like
you need to step away at times because
all moms need to hit the refresh button
it makes you go back to be a better mom
right but at the same time
you're showing your son what it's like
to be an independent working hard woman
you know he's great i was in my driveway
one day and mateo started choking but in
a way where like
i was like this seems serious i screamed
for brie
and i happen to be my friend she
happened to be in her front yard i'm
like
so i like came sprinting and like
quickly grabbing
them i was like doing this and i just
like and then i feel like i was such a
failure because in that moment i
couldn't help my son
because i was freaking out and so i was
like well this is all normal first mom
stuff
like i had to learn the hard way too
with all of it
yeah i'm just doing it the second time
so it's easier it makes you cry
your families are beautiful and i see
how happy the two of you are
do you think your families are complete
or are there hopes to expand
arnold wants to expand but i'm just so
content
and i am very driven in my career and i
love being a queer woman and i love to
travel
and i love the fact that i've i've
gotten to experience
the miracle of life and i just feel very
content at my age
like i i'm good with mateo um now his
father on the other hand would love
another one
like tomorrow oh yeah he was i mean
i feel like i have to be super careful
over here do i need to be a born-again
merchant
i'm really scared only time can tell but
like right now like
i feel like i'm a one-and-done um so
we'll see
my family's for sure done i got my boy
and my girl i'm
really happy and that's that nikki we
got to ask you for
a wedding planning update or are you not
planning a wedding because it's okay to
you know just be engaged and do you
totally um so arnold and i the other
night we sat on the couch and talked
about this i was like
do you want to start planning now and
we've called a few venues of like we
would love to be in the fall and a few
venues were like we're available
and you know what was what we just
started saying is we are so busy every
day uh completely remodeled the inside
of our home
um we haven't even lived in it yet and
so he and i both were just like let's
get through the house
like if it happens it happens i want a
really big
bash and i want to do it right and i
want it to be
like where it's a fun experience in a
journey like we're
where it's just a lot of fun so as and
now we have no plan
no dates okay if you think about your
dream scenario do you know when it would
happen and what you'd want it to look
like is it a napa wedding is it a
destination wedding
napa valley for sure in the fall because
the leaves change we could be a little
crispy cold
champagne towers black tie event
and obviously we'd have the greatest
food ever because we're here in napa
valley and then have amazing wine
and the greatest maid of honor well
that's right